in diesem sinne wäre ich mit der wahl
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch was sagen sie
toll finde
[Applaus]
und darum ist es vielleicht wirklich 40
sie ganz am anfang
das muss man auch sehr diskret machen
will natürlich wenn das publikum sie
denn hätte mir dass dieses problem kann
das wäre nicht stand
einfach aufgrund von gartner
vertrauensverhältnis mit drei berlin
das wird ihm auf
im bereich
es ist einfach ein wahnsinnig sexy es
ist ja super
[Applaus]
na gut das ist ein traditionsbruch was
es passiert ist ja in der schweiz
funktioniert normalerweise die politik
nicht so wie diesmal ein geheimplan
soder waren des bundesrates gab es nie
in der geschichte der schweiz
[Musik]
gewinnen das resultat bekannt
gewählt ist mit 121 stimmen
der wechsel war der nationalrat
christoph blocher alles beginnt mit dem
zehnten dezember 2003 christoph blocher
wird bundesweit bei der svp bei den
parlamentswahlen massiv zugelegt hat die
svp plante unter dem decknamen hannibal
parlamentswahlen vier jahre später
der slogan lautet blocher stärken svp
will am 21 oktober 2007 heißt der
wahlsieger wiederum svp parteipräsident
ueli maurer ist hochzufrieden 29 prozent
wählten seine partei
grosse wahlverliererin es sind die
sozialdemokraten
[Musik]
die wahlschlappe der spd ist der beginn
des geheimplans gegen christoph blocher
[Musik]
aktions präsidium motivation das mit
einer bundesratswahl nicht blamiert also
das aber insbesondere mindestens natur
natur wie möglich dass man nach 120
stimmen
ursula wyss ist die fraktionspräsidentin
der sozialdemokratischen partei sp
sie und zwei andere sp mitglieder haben
den plan hauptsächlich ausgearbeitet
[Applaus]
ja wir sind vergangen als hirt rottweil
zimmern fraktions präsidium darüber
diskutiert erstens also dass mehr sicher
schlosser weiter
es stimme dass man weiter versuchen sich
die grünen für sie sieht sie das ist
relativ simpel dass man aber auf
möglichst aber viele mitbürger vorzüge
deshalb unterbrochen der konkurrenz
regierung nehme haltbar ist
die erpressungen der svp entweder
blocher der opposition führen uns auch
heute vor augen dass hier jemand einen
machtanspruch stellt das sich nicht mit
unserer demokratie verträgt ja mit
herüber der name widmer schlumpf relativ
früher mal diskutiert kasse des intern
so flüchtet der wahlalternative
alternative die svp politikerin eveline
widmer schlumpf wird im jahr 1998
bündner regierungsrätin ihr vater als
bundesrat leon schlumpf ebenfalls svp
eveline widmer schlumpf leitet die
bündner finanzdirektion zehn jahre lang
ausserhalb des kantons ist sie wenig
bekannt diskret kontaktiert die sp die
bündnerin nach widmer-schlumpf trend um
die möglichkeit ihre früheren zeitpunkt
überhaupt eine möglichkeit wurden
informiert
20 november 2007 in chur im hotel stern
es ist das traditionelle parlamentarier
nach dessen der bündner regierung
vertraulich wendet sich sp nationalrat
andrea hämmerle an eveline widmer
schlumpf ich habe ihm geantwortet
das sehe ich nicht als möglichkeit tagen
ist für mich keine option weil ich
damals das habe ich damals auch gesagt
der auffassung gewesen bin dass meine
fraktion im werden nicht politisieren
kann nach mensch kommt auch vom andrea
heim metro erbeten stoppte der fortgang
dass sie das ist sie zu sehr großer
aktiv für alternative samstag erster
dezember die grüne partei nominiert luc
recordon als blocher gegenkandidaten
[Musik]
niemand weiß hier von den
geheimgesprächen der sb doch die grüne
gegenkandidatur löst eine dynamik aus
der esstisch fraktionspräsidentin der
grünen partei erinnert sich der
mediziner recht auf bad bank
tatsächlich beginnt christophe darbellay
parteipräsident der christlichen
volkspartei cvp immer offensiver und
bundesrat blocher zu zweifeln muss
verschiedene grün respekt für quartett
training stilfrage kollegialität und
auch bezüglich bilanz also da ist
wirklich kein problem sicherheit und
kriminalität sehr oft bezichtigt wurde
aber ohne dass es sehr viel gemacht
rettungs problems lösen
die cvp planung läuft unter dem
decknamen scipio ist ein general wieder
geschichte
trotz keine soldaten anzahl trainer
hannibal schlager und hannibal ist der
name von plan von bundesrat blocher
hannibal der berühmte karthagische
feldherr
er zog mit seinen truppen und elefanten
über die alpen und schlug die römer
vernichtend scipio hieß der römische
befehlshaber der 16 jahre später
hannibal besiegte dank der reiter
truppen des sunnitischen kriegsfürsten
machine is a machine is a wechselte
unter anderem die seite weil er die
schöne cutterin sofo niveau nicht halten
konnte ja das ist möchte das nicht sagen
es ist ja im diskus sie patenten und -
diskutiere mit andere partei das gehört
zum job eines präsidenten und ich
natürlich mit allen parteien reden mit
der linken keine allianz ksk und auf der
anderen seite habe ich sehr viel
gesprochen
mit der svp und mit der fdp
schlussendlich ein doch 20 bis 25 fdp
und svp bundesrat blocher nicht
unterstützen frau bestellung für ihre
stimme
dritter dezember die winter session
beginnt die öffentlichkeit geht davon
aus dass in wenigen tagen bundesrat
blocher wiedergewählt wird
doch in der cvp gärt es
ganz wichtige rolle enthalte cvp spielt
weil die cvp mit überhaupt ein
bisheriger bundesrat merz war ja der hat
einfach für sie 250 stimmen plus macht
stehen vor der grünen gar kein bundesrat
blocher kann somit dem film doch viele
über gedacht blocher der bruder von
christoph blocher als sehr viel böses
blut gar und die situation interesse
gesamthaft im parlament also china lügt
ein typisch dass man gut gebildete
kommission etwa ausschließe
ursula wyss informiert jetzt die cvp
spitze über die geheimgespräche mit
eveline widmer schlumpf streng
vertraulich
als alternative frau widmer-schlumpf
vorschlag habe wirklich eine ganz eigene
kreis vor fraktionsspitze die cvp das
größte das klar ist dass sie das auch
vorbereiter aber so das ist sicher keine
eigenen kreis bleibt das dem namen nicht
nach sonntagsmedien photoshop diskutiert
wird und das gehört zur strategie dass
es super vorbereitet wird und dass die
implementierung ziemlich schnell etwas
passieren weiß rheine stattfinden foto
es ist situation von vor inoffizieller
kandidatur untersagt oder zurückführt
dass mehr 100 prozentig auf andrea
hämmerle und auf kontakt vor ihm zur
frau widmer-schlumpf verlag bis zum bis
zum wahlgang eigentlich hätte kontakte
über den stattgefunden
[Musik]
die svp parlamentarier alle nichts von
den geheimen kontakte der sp sie sind
siegessicher
christoph blocher inklusive der
countdown läuft aber einige tag bis zu
dem ereignis wurde schmid sieht man ja
darüber redet nämlich bundesratswahl der
woche meint jetzt also für all work wir
sind schaffen momentan kriege
bundesordner chance sieht gar schädliche
größer dass sie mich wählen also zweifel
etwas gequält werden wie die prozent
waren oder höre kein geschichte zeit
fünf prozent tun nicht nur renoviert
geprägt
vor der parlamentswahl ganz viel drüber
gewährt wurde wird der herr bundesrat
blocher ist im amt bestätigt oder nicht
jetzt hat das gefühl dass eine kaste
thema mit der fast immer ist da hat nun
das laufen so gut wie gewählt wird ich
bin überzeugt bundesrat machen wird welt
und vor allem ist es wichtig dass er
wiedergewählt wird
die einzige vor ihrer sieht als chance
der herr bundesrat blocher abzuwählen
wäre ja dass sie sich offen
überparteilich akzeptierte
linksliberaler wahrscheinlich cvp
kandidat würde der eiligen oder wenn sie
jetzt kandidatur sei es für mich
selbstverständlich das modell das
militär weiter diskutieren abstiegs all
dem was planen sie es kann sehr
wichtiger teil ist dass das niemand
erwartet hätte also inklusive die ganze
medienlandschaft
samstag 8 dezember andrea hämmerle ruft
eveline widmer schlumpf an
laut hämmerle ein rund 20 minütiges
gespräch über ihre kandidatur gegen
christoph blocher dahingehend geführt
bis zum akzeptieren vorwahl viele
schicksal doch nicht ganz so haye
herausfordern sondern mit nummer bis zum
wahlgang tritt also klar hätte was
müssen sie das sind nicht vor der wahl
am 12 dezember upside und ab springt
werde konkret sieht vor den special
teams dazu habe sagt er es gemacht kann
es mir sehr auf dem laufenden halten wie
es hier in bundesbahn passiert das ist
stadt mach ich sie für österreichs
entwickelt
entwickler und konkret wurde es über das
informiert
willi wittmann schlumpf stellt den
kontakt mit der sp anders dar
neben dem nachtessen aber es nur noch
ein sms am dienstagabend gegeben
ich habe am dienstagabend ein sms
die fantasiestücke op
ms ms project falcon aus der
bundesversammlung im jahr fach
informiert und ich habe dann am
dienstagabend also vorgestern abend eine
sms erhalten
[Musik]
das stehe zu die diskussion ob es dann
mein name sei oder einnahmen der ist
immer noch nicht anderthalb monate nach
der wahl das traditionelle suche bis
essen der svb
[Musik]
ehrengäste sind bundesrätin widmer
schlumpf und bundesrat samuel schmid
[Applaus]
schweizer vereinssatzung stark in frage
stellen
denn zwei tagen zwei mal kontakt mit dem
hermelin feststellen
eine schöne möglichkeit zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt die frage zu
beantworten ob das genick
doch das interview kommt nie zustande
eveline widmer schlumpf lässt kurz
danach schriftlich ausrichten
sie werde dazu keine fragen mehr
beantworten noch drei tage bis zur wahl
sonntag neunter dezember die
sonntagszeitung positionierte abb als
bundesratskandidaten gestützt auf die
aussage er aber noch nie eine wahl
verweigert
am nächsten tag im parlament
gratulationen für den walliser die
journalisten vom sonntags tätig erzählt
macht s 2 zwischen 2
aber eigentlich muss ich sagen das
nachwirken sehr gute wirklichkeit
tatsächlich spekulieren die medien nun
die cvp werde versuchen einen zweiten
bundesratssitz zu erobern
gegen christoph blocher
sie wurde jetzt am sonntag wie viele
schweizer und schweizerinnen das glas
natürlich informiert dass ich genau das
braucht er hat im lauf vor dem wahlkampf
für k s weiter drüber gut foto schweiz
hat das auf sich fokussiert hat sich
vorstellt gefühlt und ich glaube dem
wahlkampf hatte radlern aus kühlkörper
und die sogar bundesrat werfe alles wo
abgelenkt und medienschaffende abgelenkt
hoffen wir noch vorstellbar meine
position ist jetzt bundes wirklich ein
mikrokosmos ziemlich jeder von jedem
alles also da ich mein eigentum
verlangen das ist das ist also sehr viel
blut dass chemnitz dienstag nachmittag
elfter dezember der tag vor der wahl
die cvp trifft sich zur fraktionssitzung
christophe darbellay hat diese zum
geschickt zu einem medialen höhepunkt
gemacht
erst an diesem tag entscheidet die cvp
ob sie morgen blocher wählen wird oder
nicht
angeblich kennen nicht einmal präsident
darbellay
das genaue ergebnis der tvp interne
blocher abstimmung der
fraktionsvertreter habe die stimmzettel
nach der auszählung vernichtet sagt die
cvp nach der geheimen abstimmung
informiert der cvp fraktionspräsident
urs schwaller die mädchen hatte nicht
gedacht dass es ein so großes interesse
auslösen würde
punkt nummer eins die cvp fraktion hält
die coco-bonds hoch das heißt wir wollen
die einbindung das rechte der vier
wichtigsten parteien auch weiterhin den
bogen bis 8 für uns heißt das dass wir
die zweisitzer sv fälle und beschreibt
keine mehrheit findet bundesrat
christoph blocher
die cvp evp glp fraktion wird aber nicht
mit einem kandidaten gegen bundesrat
noch bei anträgen und wird auch nicht
länger gordon unterstützen schwan weiß
bereits am nächsten mal hinter der seine
funktion auffordern wird nur stumpf auf
den stimmzettel zu schreiben
doch erneut liegt die cvp eine falsche
fährte
gruppe oder aus der svp irgendwelche
gespräche geführt
ich gehe davon aus dass hier die stimmen
sich noch während die pressekonferenz
läuft geht der cvp fraktion sekretär zur
spitze der sp und der grünen obmann im
bundes und das meer ist der nachfrage
nach dem teilverbot und den rückzug für
diskutieren mit hey östliche aus
hauptstadt gratis cvp zh ist das thema
behandelt hätte man vom vormittag und
nachmittag in kenntnis achtet und das
hätte für die sp spitze ist der morgen
klar
der grüne luc recordon sieht seine
kandidatur am nächsten tag zurück das
manöver könnte gelingen
doch jetzt der fährt ueli maurer
gerichte weise von den absprachen er
versucht eveline widmer schlumpf
anzurufen
nach der fraktionssitzung versucht mit
ihren kontakten
das ist einzigartig sie dass sie dann
nicht vermutlich hatten mit äußerer
kantonalpräsidentin von graubünden gerät
mit barbara janom und sie frage die
situation beurteilen sie hat mich seit
vor dem buffet zigarren vize galliani
vor dem signiertes gehört aber sie traf
sich hat einmalig mit der damit im
rahmen eines und sie sagte dass sie mehr
sind zu kitten
christoph tabelle erhält inzwischen von
cvp fraktion sekretär die bestätigung
dass die grünen rekorde am nächsten tag
zurückziehen werden zur sicherheit legt
arabella nochmals eine falsche fährte
und in der grieche richtig an ihm vor
aber vor der wahl für den 12 12
annika svp namen nach die polit damit
nicht der ganze druck sich versieht hat
und frau widmer schlumpf es gibt gute
kandidaten aus der svp wird trägt die
hauptadresse op also ich meine einen
nationalrat super g titel um was es geht
dabei sehr glaubwürdig und guten namen
ja also bisher wurden die diversesten
namen genannt ich weiß nicht ob ich die
jetzt alle wiederholen sollen beim
beschluss ist ein name dann gibt es
einen namen wie zu picken
dann gibt es den namen bade dann gibt es
die einen die sagen es soll jemand aus
der fraktion im bundeshaus sein jemand
welche die sagen es soll jemand von
außerhalb sein
wir werden jetzt die diskussion mit der
cvp führen und schauen wie wir morgen
vorgehen kann
das ist das war mal etc diesmal viel
besser gemacht hat dass man das mal hier
mit denner pastor am schluss stimmzettel
der wahlzettel hat es mal mit
öffentlichkeit
juli parteipräsident der liberalen fdp
sagt er habe erst an jedem dienstag von
den geheimen absprachen erfahren
dienstagabend wird zum ersten mal die
namen der möglichen kandidaten gehört
dazu gehörte auch dass mit in der name
von frau widmer schlumpf haben uns
gefragt ob sie bereit wäre und so einem
spiel teilzunehmen
er leitet bei uns war die über
sonja das sehen was sie am tag vorher
erzählt wird habe die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass etwas passiert ist klein
die svp bleibt an diesem abend
siegessicher
die gerüchte über widmer schlumpf machen
beim abendessen zwar die runde
aber man ist nicht besorgt
vor dem ersten wahlgang knapp gewählt
wird der regel in west hollywood
und jetzt sechs namen gehört natürlich
werden einige von denen vielleicht 20 14
8 also spart das wetter keine pläne aber
einen auffälligen wagen ist ein
offizieller kandidat richtung woche riss
sie haben wieder einen viertel vor zwölf
winter durchmesser und eva sie fragt wie
situation beurteilen ist so wenig sind
beim beurteile hexe [ __ ] reli
wahlchancen und sie hat mir seid ja das
komitee ioc kauf des gehörs unfall
fallen wie sich überhaupt keine angst
dass sie so eine wahl wird jana wenn sie
bis sie das in bayern ohne fraktionen
könnte politisiere bin mit anderen auch
vorher nochmal einen regierungsentscheid
von der fraktion zurückgestellt aus
oberrotweil würde ludwig lipp oder
fraktion weil das ist informiert dass
frau widmer schlumpf am tisch das
telefon hebt offen heraus ist es schon
richtig informiert sie das kassierte sie
das größte hätte gewusst dass das
eigentlich vor dem telefonat dass ein
schnitt müsste ich bin wirklich neue
muss ich im nachhinein feststellen will
ich dann fifa droht wieder gefunden weil
man sich während acht jahre kommt immer
mit der übergangsrat wird sie mich aber
informieren
ich bin auch den telefons fritte wir
hatten nur 70 oder partei tritt zurück
der kreisausschuss der sitzungszeit
widmer schlumpf ist das problem sind das
amt nieder wir sind ein relativ sicheres
thematik dass die wahl klappert und sind
ganz sicher dass sie die wahl nicht
werten
die svp ist beruhigt währenddessen im
hotel bellevue ausgewählte
parlamentarier werden jetzt in wigan
operation eingeweiht
sp nationalrat christian levrat und
christophe darbellay informieren
erstmals den grünen nationalrat ueli
leuenberger links im bild die
verschwörer besprechen sie um
mitternacht die details des geheimen
manövers medizin viel mitglied müsse
diskutieren einzel bearbeitung
überzeugungsarbeit leisten und das haben
wir nicht mit druck mache also da muss
man wirklich mit argumenten operieren
und das hat man müsse wirklich mit fleiß
und gut gesund machen
[Applaus]
wichtig ist sieht ist all diejenigen
parlamentarier der fraktion sexy war
weil eigentlich offiziell bundesrat
blocher quartal und das sauber aber
nicht macht hey wie zum beispiel dick
marty fdp dissidenten fahrt was das was
cvp und sp grüne wettermacher zwölfter
dezember alltag luc recordon steht
frühmorgens im rampenlicht die medien
ahnen nicht dass er sich schon aus dem
rennen genommen hat das
ablenkungsmanöver funktioniert wo
kranjcar und wohin welche deklaration im
parlament quartett island überhaupt
nicht was da abläuft 7 uhr morgens erst
jetzt informieren die spitzen der spd
cvp und der grünen ihre parteikollegen
über widmer schlumpf und sieben am
morgen vor der fraktion und die rauxel
was ist das ganze fahrzeug sie konkret
mit b2 svp-bundesrat midway dass man
namen hat wenn man mehrheitlich nicht
alt bundesrat blocher rituelle
unterstützen und auch heran ich den
namen erwähnten verbieten schlug und wie
man das schreibt die fraktion ihres
prominenten mitbieter nach des dreiliter
aufgeschrieben ist reaktionen ziemlich
und zwar einfach darum weil irgendein
bis dramatische sender bis aufregendes
erwartet aus witten schlumpf
das ist wirklich ein wenn es meist
europa also mannheim auf das gewartet
ergo ist dass das gequake diskussion
erst zwei minuten abkühlen die letzte
wohnung schlafen verwahrten sofort
gemerkt das ist einfach also fragt man
geht auch die svp trifft sich zur
morgendlichen fraktionssitzung mit dabei
christoph blocher ueli maurer
telefoniert nochmals mit eveline widmer
schlumpf ich kann ihre seit das hat sich
zugespitzt über auch du musst damit
rechne dass du gut gewählt wird er halt
die studie von 10x eigentlich nicht aber
der muss keine angst ich weiß dass ich
ohne fraktion die politisierung wenig
die sitzung ist zu ende jetzt geht es
zur wahl
mir macht klar dass ab vom moment aber
die fraktion seitige stattfindende
öffentlichkeit und der wandelhalle zeit
und das alte niveau interessiert sich
die kandidatur ruft über dieses thema
sei das mit einer offensiv der name sei
die folge verwirrung überraschen
unglaube nicht genau verstanden was
jetzt noch kandidat im moment aber nicht
nein nein weil wir haben nun die
sicherheit dass frau widmer-schlumpf der
svp graubünden eine wahl annehmen würde
und deshalb lohnt es sich unsere
kandidatur zurückzuziehen ich habe immer
gesagt meine kandidatur ist wie ein
schild und das schild soll am letzten so
spät wie möglich aufgehoben werden und
erschwert kommt und frau widmer schlumpf
war das werk
die svp bleibt trotzdem optimistisch
praktisch zur gleichen zeit eveline
widmer schlumpf fährt nach bern zu
traditionellen svp-fraktion setzen
betont sie im bundeshaus werden die
stimmzettel ausgeteilt wahlgang fünf
wiederwahl christoph blocher ursula wyss
hat durchgesetzt dass die blogger gegner
bereits im ersten wahlgang nur widmer
schlumpf auf den stimmzettel schreiben
wenn sich die stimme verzerrt die also
das bestimme und die grüne stimme und
nachher vor allen anderen er anders als
bundesrat blocher hochgeschrieben
der schock vom ersten wahlgang das
mieten schlumpf mehr stimmen konnte
tauss blocher dass der rettungsplan den
beiden zweiter wahlgang sei
wahrscheinlich
er kennt sich der politiker verstehen
wir nahmen damit
für bösch der woche noch und die welt
das manöver gelingt eveline widmer
schlumpf überrundet christoph blocher
bereits im ersten wahlgang die
überraschung ist perfekt
die blogger gegner sind bereits
unmittelbar vor resultat bekanntgabe
entspannt und gelöst
weshalb hat die geheime operation so gut
funktioniert meine kritik amtsführung
von bundesrat und parlament ali jinnah
parlamentarier stimmung und 8 und wir
jetzt bundesrat blocher hier regiert
öffnet nicht akzeptiert und worte
sorgsam die ganze session am schloss
endlich absolut sicher dass es sap gibt
bundesrat blocher die svp dementiert und
beschuldigt die fdp
wir haben bitte fdp zimmer fußgänger das
sax oder 7 bewertet wie wähle dass
dieser wert lag mit hand mit den
rückritt und ich an und sie stieg
benommen nun ins gespräch kam mit dem
fulvio pelli unter gabi huber
und die haben wir bei die namen
versicherter seiner fraktion und
wertherbruch geschrieben aber die liegt
garantiert die ziel war nicht blocher
nicht wiederzuwählen ziel von dieser
leute war selber sich zu enthalten und
nicht die verantwortungs aufzunehmen
diese wahl zu bevorzugen und in diesem
sinne haben sie wahrscheinlich so er
handelt wie sie gesagt habe und fdp hat
hat die europa league gemacht wo wir mit
ihnen ab mochte dieser entscheid wurde
organisiert von der cvp an der linken
und von den grünen und ich glaube man
muss dort bleiben bei diejenige die das
entschieden haben nicht bei uns wir
wollen keine wir wollen nicht
betrachtet werden als diejenige die das
organisiert damit das haben wir nicht
organisiert das war gegen unserer
strategie unsere strategie war eine
andere und das war für die ganze
fraktion eine andere der zweite
entscheidende wahlgang
die stimmzettel werden verteilt uli
maurer versucht nochmals frau
widmer-schlumpf anzurufen
ich bin immer voraus dass die beiden
frauen aus der privaten beschluss vom 3
jetzt völlig unvorbereitet den zug
richtung bayern fahrt überhaupt
klinikern ich ständig versucht kontakt
mit dem etwas schlumpf hat ihr handy
der svb kantonalpräsidentin diana
übergeben
ich habe sie selbst und telefonie
präsidenten seit 20 minuten bis die
bundesrätin
wir reagieren und die hand
und damals war die 242 sommer durch
absolutes mehr von 622 mio
gewählt ist mit 125 stimmen man dann
widmer schlumpf
[Applaus]
jetzt auf
ok
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
wenige minuten später trifft sie in
zürich ein frau widmann ich gratuliere
zum resultat nehmen sie die wahl als
bundesrätin an
das wäre die hintere stunden zwei
stunden deutlich dass den offiziell es
sei egal was sie machen und ich weiß
auch dass es für alles was man im leben
macht den richtigen zeitpunkt aber neben
auf den falschen zeitpunkt geben und ich
werde nicht danach richten
tatsächlich zweifelt sie in diesem
moment ob sie die wahl
und so wie sich später bestätigte ich
habe mir dann gestern im zug und dann
nach dieser wahl habe ich mich mich
ernsthaft gefragt ja ist dass sie
überhaupt möglich wenn man mir kritisch
und sagt dass man keine chance hat gegen
die fraktion aufgenommen zu werden und
ich musste mir das wirklich überlegen
und das war auch der grund warum wir den
scheiß so schwer gefallen ist
es ist also super sache
ich bin total überrascht dass es trocken
ist
der will ihn bieten ausgezeichnete
bundeskanzlers wege
wenn also überrascht alle sind total
überrascht
total ist viel zeit aber ziemlich
was sie die wahl nicht wird erwartet
dass vor ihre machen ohne fraktion haben
im bundesrat nicht politisch wäre das
gar nicht christophe darbellay ist die
ruhe selbst erst überzeugt dass fitness
stimmt akzeptieren wird
ich habe solide und nika aber der regel
nicht direkt mit ihrer kritik vorsieht
die solide garantieren
ich werde das nicht zeigen inzwischen
organisiert maurer dass die svp widmer
schlumpf diskret in einem neben flügel
des bundeshauses treffen kann
um 13 uhr trifft sie ein und bespricht
sich mit der svp parteispitze
doch
mit bedroht wurde von parteimitglied
fraktionsmitglied oder vom
parteivorstand aber mit mehr klar sein
dass konsequenzen wenige wahl an die
rückseite sind nicht in den
fraktionsvorstand der ihnen gucken mit
mir gesagt dass nicht die politik von
mir in jedem fall mit metall gefertigt
also insofern hat man mit offenen karten
gespielt aber dafür bin ich dankbar dass
sie in genau größte favela die
svp-spitze alt nach dem gespräch zur
fraktion zurück in der annahme eveline
widmer schlumpf lehne
höchstwahrscheinlich die wahl ab
sie hat seit sie sind völlig blind
placebo spezialität
jetzt soll sich das über leckerbissen am
morgen
ich bin immer noch davon ausgegangen
dass sie dass sie die reise einfach so
wenig sie keine treppen und die
geschätzt haben er würde in widmer
schlumpf erhält bedenkzeit bis zum
nächsten tag
sie entschließt sich zuerst ihren
parteikollegen bundesrat samuel schmid
zu konsultieren
das treffen spielt für ihren entscheid
eine wichtige rolle
anderthalb monate später die beiden
bundesräte am bielersee besessen
schmidt sagt dass widmer-schlumpf
fälschlicherweise annahm
nur sie weder aus der fraktion
ausgeschlossen
er habe sie aufgeklärt
fraktionszwang
the space ist groß
kurz nach diesem gespräch reist eveline
widmer schlumpf zurück ins bündnerland
situation und ich habe verständnis wenn
sie jetzt mal bei angst ich will sie
haben wollen müssen wir das wieder gut
sie muss sich ein quasi wenn sie zurzeit
wenn ich sie den ärger von ferner
wählerinnen und wähler die partei in 13
der dezember frühmorgens auf dem
bundesplatz anhänger von eveline widmer
schlumpf versammeln sich zur gleichen
zeit eveline widmer schlumpf fährt
erneut richtung bern
stärken
[Musik]
bewacht von zivilpolizisten macht sie
sich auf in richtung bundeshaus die
ganze schweiz wartet mit spannung auf
ihren entscheid
ja oder nein
phz
das sagen so macht bewacht prozent
es wäre dass sie aus und das parlament
entscheiden
präsident der bundesversammlung wer sie
haben geschätzt die damen und herren mir
mit dieser wahl gästen
ich kann diese nur wahrnehmen wenn ich
auf jeden bestimmt so zählen
mit seiner ganzen kraft in diese aufgabe
den 1
geschätzte damen und herren
wenn die genießen
auf ihnen zu oft gerate
auch immer wieder unterschiedliche
meinungen haben das gerät in
demokratischen system das ist gelebte
demokratie
so lassen sie uns doch einander stets
mit respekt und toleranz begegnen in
diesem sinne kläre ich anna moderat
[Applaus]
sie standen durch jp morgan
fortschritten sms sich das gut überlegt
und sie sich bereit zusammen
die särge nach ihrer rede erläutert die
neue bundesrätin weshalb sie das amt
doch noch angenommen hat ich habe mir
dann gesagt ja das ist offensichtlich
doch nicht so dass wenn die fraktion
eine aufnahme ablehnt dass dann die
ganze svp schweiz diese auffassung
vertreten die und meine bündner partei
sie hat sich sehr klar auch gewesen die
geheime operation hat funktioniert
das ganz verliebt und aber überhaupt
nicht nur sie sondern wie die
bürgerliche krise wieder auf stufe 3 d
grafik befragt wurden vom new york wo da
die letzten vier jahre als person
fixiert es sie dass man gar kein spaß
mehr politiker
ich schwanke zwischen erleichterung und
eine wunderbar das werden sie verstehen
warum empörung ein ich wenigen weil sie
einen an den bundesrat gewählt haben
sondern wie sie es getan haben
parlamente können zwar leute aus der
regierung empfehlen aber nicht aus der
politik und nicht aus der politischen
schaffen im land
[Applaus]
es ist absolut richtig dass 30 prozent
sap welt hat das auch wegen christoph
blocher dass du nicht entgegen
auf der anderen seite also ist parlament
gemessen fast und setzte in der lage
zwei bärisch der beste aber wer ist die
beste bundesrat ihn für diese partei und
das ist das ist ganz große glocke dass
man diese analyse gemüse machen und dass
eine mehrheit wie es eine mehrheit des
parlamentes christoph blocher gerichtet
weil unterstützen verbraucher hat sie
mehrmals besiegt nicht inhaltlich aber
politisch und sie tragen sie haben diese
situation ganz einfach nicht getragen
serben liebert dass er nicht in die
regierung ist weil in die regierung kann
er auf die politik eine wirkung haben
viel mehr als als oppositionspolitiker
ende dezember christoph blocher auf dem
weg zur amtsübergabe frau widmen muss
jetzt im nachhinein sagen rainer
corriere mensch sie wird dem bundesrat
der wand
also sie wird für ihre karriere worden
und weniger für schland vorstellen und
ähnliche ich das wirklich schwierige von
sexy und hatte sie das irgendwann brand
völlig unter wenigen erklärt aber dass
es nach risiko nie ganz dunkel
[Musik]
er muss natürlich sehe ich eigentlich
meine meinung nicht primär frau widmer
quält wurden als buntes reutin sondern
primär ist herr blocher abgewählt wurde
und dann habe ich einfach drüber gesucht
wo man bist hat dass die wesentlichen
fragen abwegige hat zum port de per fuß
gemacht dass ich noch schick grüne
händlern und mittelbar macht und
erfolgsbesessen überhaupt nicht mit
grossen teils des jemals rentieren das
werde und dass sich unter ihrem ganz
zentral stadtverwaltung wert verloren
[Musik]
und dann geht er mit treicheln
verabschiedet von seinen anhängern
[Applaus]